Traduttore: Riccardo Fraccaro
Revisore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Sono qui per condividere con voi alcune
esperienze nell'ambito dell'energia.
Ho avuto la fortuna di girare Giappone,
Cina, Stati Uniti e America Latina
occupandomi proprio di analizzare
situazioni di business
nelle varie parti del mondo
per le energie.
Ho maturato quindi
tutta una situazione mondiale
che mi permette
di condividere con voi alcune situazioni.
Non vi parlerò quindi di kilowattora,
ma vi parlerò di come questi sistemi,
di come questo modo di concepire l'energia
che sta evolvendo in questi ultimi anni
potrà determinare il nostro futuro,
e vi voglio guidare
attorno a questo concetto.
Noi finora, permettetemi,
ho la spada di maestro Yoda,
abbiamo avuto una evoluzione del sistema
delle energie abbastanza lineare:
attraverso varie tecnologie,
buone o cattive che siano,
siamo arrivati a parlare oggi
di energie rinnovabili
Bene, le energie rinnovabili
hanno molto di più sotto di loro,
hanno delle cose che veramente
ci danno da pensare per il futuro.
C'è questo mondo e questa è la figura
completa di come si sta evolvendo.
Questo è preso grazie alla Duke Power,
una delle aziende che si sta
maggiormente impegnando
nel determinare nuovi sistemi di energia.
Come vedete ci sono parole importanti,
anche molto al di fuori dei soliti
concetti di energia.
Su questo entreremo nel merito
e vi voglio dare qualche spunto
su come sono collegati al nostro futuro.
Per esempio, si parla molto di impianti
solari, quello che mettete sopra al tetto.
Questo è un qualcosa che veramente
abilita tanti aspetti.
Per esempio, potrebbe fare in modo
che la nostra abitazione
ci desse dei soldi.
Non è una cosa brutta pensare questo eh,
o avere questo tipo di situazione.
Oggi ci stanno provando concretamente
aziende importanti e start-up
che stanno veramente considerando
come poter fare in modo che l'azienda
e la casa, diventino qualcosa
che dia un profitto.
Questi sono esempi di prodotti
che sono già in commercio.
Questi sono, però, prodotti
legati a quei prodotti
che sono più tecnologici
da un punto di vista
di information technology
e che portano a sviluppare tutta una serie
di sistemi e piattaforme
di altissimo valore perché permettono
di mettere insieme tante altre cose.
Chiaramente,
avendo questo tipo di possibilità,
si creano tutti questi tipi di nuovi
settori industriali e di nuove innovazioni
Ma vi dirò di più: con un sistema di
energie innovative si parla di ecosistema,
una parola abbastanza in voga ultimamente,
specialmente nei business ICT.
Però qui si parla di usare questo
ecosistema per creare nuovi modi,
nuove città, nuovi posti
dove vivere meglio
e, soprattutto, più al passo coi tempi
perché la realtà che stiamo vivendo
tutti vede una corsa all'innovazione,
una corsa all'introduzione di cose
talmente nuove che ci perdiamo per strada.
Le città ci possono venire in aiuto
se sono concepite pensando,
da questo punto di vista,
con l'energia al primo posto.
Città che sono organizzate
in una certa maniera,
facilitano lo scambio di esperienze,
competenze, ma anche di valori economici.
Ci sono già degli esempi
ed è possibile visitarli:
li abbiamo in Giappone, Toyota City.
Toyota non è solo una casa
che produce automobili,
ha tutto un investimento enorme,
forse ancora più grande dell'auto,
nel campo immobiliare.
Stanno pensando città
e le hanno già realizzate,
già organizzate per poter vivere
in una certa maniera,
usando bene l'energia, spendendo poco
e avendo tutti i servizi attorno.
Ti danno anche il tipo di casa che vuoi,
a seconda dei tuoi modi e stili di vita,
comprese le auto elettriche
(in quel caso, chiaramente sono le loro).
Ma ci sono altre città
che stanno affrontando questo tema
dal punto di vista dell'energia
e cercano di mettere insieme
dei sistemi energetici, guardate questo
ad esempio, con creatività
C'è tutto un fermento
attorno a questi temi.
Non possiamo pensare
di avere sistemi di energia innovativi
se non abbiamo delle cose innovative
dentro le case, attorno a noi, eccetera.
Questo oggi è chiamato Internet of Things.
Internet of Things, se lo guardiamo
dal punto di vista dei sistemi energetici,
potrebbe diventare foriero
di una nuova Silicon Valley
perché apre tutta una serie di possibilità
e di necessità di investimenti tecnologici
che possono in qualche misura permettere
di rendere bilanciati i sistemi di energia
e di usare le case e le energie
in maniera intelligente, ma non solo.
Potrebbero, anzi danno sicuramente luogo
a un sacco di informazioni,
devono essere basati
su intelligenza artificiale.
Cosa che magari pochi conoscono,
possono, grazie a queste tecnologie
da poco entrate in auge,
essere monetizzabili.
Non entro nei dettagli,
ma pensate a questo:
se concepiamo un sistema energetico
basato sulle energie innovative
e questo con tutti questi paradigmi,
ci potrebbe permettere di avere
delle forme di denaro e di pagamenti
e di scambi di valore molto particolari
grazie alle tecnologie
che ci sono associate.
E chiaramente,
l'abbondanza di informazioni
che questi sistemi creano
e l'abbondanza di capacità di calcolo,
disponibile in questi ultimi anni,
ci permetterebbe di creare nuovi business
e inventare nuovi servizi.
La parola chiave
per gli addetti ai lavori in questi anni
sono le digital platform,
le piattaforme digitali.
Queste sono ben note in certi ambienti
come Apple, Google, Amazon.
Nel campo dell'energia,
le piattaforme digitali non ci sono.
Quelle che ci sono, sono poche
e sono in embrione,
quindi siamo al punto di partenza
di queste cose.
Potremmo pensare che,
se ci lavoriamo bene, su questo fronte
potremmo creare la Google dell'energia.
E anche questa non è una cosa da poco
perché voi sapete che oggi il mondo...
questi signori qua, che rappresentano
le piattaforme oggi disponibili
sui vari continenti, fatturano,
o meglio, hanno un PIL
proporzionale a tanti paesi vicini a noi.
Quello che voglio dirvi, in conclusione,
è che se ci guardiamo attorno,
se guardiamo i nostri vicini e noi stessi,
a come competere con altri paesi, etc.,
la domanda che ci possiamo porre
è: "hai l'energia innovativa?"
Se ce l'hai, vuol dire
che hai sviluppato tutte queste cose,
quindi ci siamo creati un futuro
da questo punto di vista.
Non hai le energie innovative?
Allora resti indietro.
Questa è la morale.
In altri termini, le energie innovative,
quelle "giuste",
mettiamole tra virgolette,
sono dei catalizzatori
di un sacco di investimenti,
di grandi evoluzioni future,
di grandi sviluppi.
E quindi, in conclusione,
quale energia vogliamo avere?
Io, dopo questa sintesi e questo lavorare
in giro per il mondo, ho le idee chiare
e spero di avere dato anche a voi
qualche spunto positivo su questo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)